schlange stehen in berlin warten auf den
pcr test viele bürger sind genervt
sie zierte symptome und er ist reine
durch die gegend und zu alter stärke
die letzten beiden male gegen die
schlange bis kann aber erst mal
nicht nur in berlin in ganz deutschland
gibt es engpässe bei den pcr tests in
die labore kommen nicht hinterher mit
der auswertung dabei wären pcr tests
besonders wichtig um in der mikrowelle
nicht unterzugehen
der pcr test ist heute der goldstandard
gegen den alle anderen testverfahren
bewertet werden und der pcr test hat
darüber hinaus noch die möglichkeit
zumindest ein indikator für die virus
laster zu bieten doch statt gold
standard ist in deutschland der bürger
ist weniger präzise stadt pcr nur
antigen schnelltest eine
fehlentscheidung deutscher
gesundheitspolitik ist benjamin völkers
berger überzeugt er betreibt 50
testzentren
engpässe gibt das sehen wir überhaupt
nicht so wir könnten jederzeit die
kapazitäten im labor hochfahren
die behörden beauftragung und
staffelleiter aber nicht und es wird
auch keinen grund genannt warum nicht
sein problem er gehört nicht zu den
akkreditierten laboren die die kosten
für den pcr test letztlich vom staat
erstattet bekommen dabei verspricht
völkers berger deutlich niedrigere
preise wir bieten die pcr test für 14
euro 99 an
das ist also deutlich günstiger als die
alteingesessenen labore die über 40 euro
bekommen und von den privat saarland zum
teil über 150 euro wenn man nach wien
guckt dann geht es definitiv günstiger
wien hier sind während der pandemie
einfache pcr test verfahren zugelassen
worden hier gibt es den google test eine
salzlösung eine minute im mund gekurbelt
dann in ein röhrchen gespuckt fertig ist
die probe
identifizierung per google app vor dem
smartphone die probe kann überall
abgegeben werden drogerie tankstelle
oder supermarkt
in diesem labor werden die proben
ausgewertet bis zu 800.000 pcr tests am
tag das wiener modell der pcr bürger
test diesen goldstandard aber gibt es in
deutschland nicht unsere idee war heute
möglichst viele dies zu der besten
qualität zu einem extrem günstigen preis
zu machen in deutschland hat man anderes
geschäftsmodell das hat man mal wieder
möglichst wenig nächstes machen zu
möglichst hohen preis alles gurgelt
kinderleicht heißt es in wien für die
stadt hat sich der einfache bürger test
ausgezahlt wir zahlen jetzt im
augenblick unter sechs euro für einen
test so ist glaube ich vertretbar aber
es ist natürlich nichts gegen die
volkswirtschaftlichen kosten auch nur
von einem tal glock da also ein tag
lockt dann kostet es mehr als wir halbes
jahr google ist in der stadt ein pcr
test kostet in wien also sechs euro in
deutschland zahlt der bund zwischen 43
und 83 euro schon vor zwei jahren hatte
karl lauterbach für den wiener google
test geworben jetzt als
bundesgesundheitsminister ist er
deutlich zurückhaltender wieso machen
wir das nicht in wien gepolte test usw
geburt es hätten dazu geführt dass wir
jetzt eine höhere kapazität hätten aber
so etwas muss man vorberaten und zwar
bevorzugt zu dem zeitpunkt wo es nicht
viele fälle gibt denn wenn sie die
labors umstellen wollen ein solches
verfahren machen sie das am besten wenn
nicht gerade so eine große belastung ist
jetzt wäre das vollkommen unmöglich der
deutsche dax-konzern kia gehen hat die
pz technik für wien entwickelt wir
zeigen den kia den manager kai techart
die aussage des gesundheitsministers
ist nicht vollkommen möglich wir sehen
derzeit kunden die umstellen unter dem
druck gekommen wäre um weitere
kapazitäten zu schaffen in 40 ländern
werden die industrialisierten pc
massentests von kirchen eingesetzt nicht
aber in deutschland obwohl dieses
verfahren hohe kapazitäten schafft und
zuverlässiger ist als antigen
schnelltests kia gehen verspricht
billigere tests weil die auswertung im
labor nur knapp eine stunde dauere
herkömmliche pc analysen brauchen bis zu
fünf stunden und deutlich mehr personal
die kia den manager und andere deutsche
anbieter konnten bund und länder nicht
von den vereinfachten und preiswerteren
pcr tests überzeugen die technologie
wurde unter anderem ende april 21 in
einer roundtable diskussion mit dem
bundesministerium für gesundheit und dem
mysterium für wirtschaft vorgestellt
auch mit anderen industrie teilnehmern
mit werden reaktion das war ein
sondierungsgespräch und resonanz nach
diesem meeting hat das aus unserer sicht
keine gegeben wie kommentieren sie das
soll ich da sagt mehrfach kontakte
angeboten und wir haben keine resonanz
bekommen
corona test sind in deutschland ein
milliardengeschäft auch für die
akkreditierten labor wir fragen nach
beim kölner großlabor will spring hof
wollen uns preise und kosten erklären
lassen kein interview wir werden
verwiesen an den dachverband der medizin
labor l m wir stoßen auf intensiver
lobby aktivitäten des labor verband ist
als im november
2021 die bundesregierung deutlich mehr
labore für die pcr tests zu lassen
wollte schreibt der lm dem
gesundheitsministerium die konkurrenz
sei weder fachlich ausgebildet noch
seien von ihr
qualitätssicherungsmaßnahmen zu erwarten
weitere vorwürfe die konkurrenz hatte
weder die meldepflicht bei positiven
befunden ein noch die gesetzlichen
vorschriften der allem fordert wörtlich
für den neuen gesetzestext dass die
weiteren anbieter grundsätzlich
gestrichen werden
es ist nicht das erste mal elisabeth
müller betreibt mehrere veterinäre buche
als die bundesregierung im frühjahr
2021 tierärztliche labore für pcr tests
zu lassen wollte wurde die entscheidende
passage über nacht gestrichen
verschwand dann sehr sehr schnell aus
dem gesetzesentwurf und auf nachfrage
wer das veranlasst hat ist mir keine
schlüssige antwort gegeben worden die
interessensgruppen sind natürlich im
vorfeld gefragt worden und da ist auch
klar geworden dass die humanmediziner
zumindest der meinung waren sie hätten
eine ausreichende kapazität aufgebaut da
bräuchte es niemanden zur seite und sie
hätten schließlich auch viel investiert
und da wollten sie dann auch zu ihrem
recht kommen wir fragen nach beim labor
verband der held die preise für pcr
tests in deutschland für gerechtfertigt
und zum vorwurf die gesetzgebung
beeinflusst zu haben heißt es zitat bei
der korona virus test verordnung handelt
es sich um einen ausgewogenen
politischen prozess ergebnis des
prozesses lange schlangen vor den kopf
von allen testzentren engpässe in den
laboren und milliardenkosten für
steuerzahler wir fragen nach beim
bundesgesundheitsminister der verteidigt
die akkreditierten laboren die hätten in
der pandemie erheblich investieren
müssen schriftlich heißt es es seien die
spezifischen sonderkosten zu
berücksichtigen und in der vergütung
entsprechend abzubilden inzwischen macht
die opposition im bundestag druck
das wiener modell ist einfach zu
handhaben
wir können schnell viele menschen damit
erreichen das ist effektiv es ist
kostengünstig und vor allem können wir
sequenzieren das heißt für die zukunft
wenn neue varianten auf deutschland
zukommt wissen wir viel viel zeitiger
welche variante in deutschland ist ob es
eine tödlichere variante ist oder nur
eine ansteckende variante und deswegen
sollten wir das modell auftritt statt
ausruhen das
bundesgesundheitsministerium sieht dafür
keinen anlass mit dem segen des
ministers dürfen die akkreditierten
labor weiter kasse machen und die bürger
weiter schlange stehen